jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen über süßigkeiten nachgedacht
und dachten wir es wäre vielleicht ganz
lustig ein video zu machen indem ich
süßigkeiten auf eine art und weise wie
man es normalerweise niemals tun würde
und da ich gerade sowieso ultrabook habe
auf süßigkeiten würde ich sagen wir
fangen direkt am beginnen wir mit nummer
eins dem überraschungsei in der mädchen
version so leute was glaubt jetzt wie
könnte man ein mädchen überraschungs ei
essen wenn nicht wie ganz normal wir
beginnen indem wir es wie üblich helens
mattel oder stellen oder was auch immer
zum glück haben wir noch ein nicht ein
gedecktes überraschungsei was wir als
ersatz benutzen können aber dafür für
jung wir kennen das überraschungsei
wurde jetzt eingestellt ist und jetzt
brauchen wir eine gewisse sache ein
eierbecher da packen wir das
überraschungsei rein und jetzt beginnen
wir unsere überraschungs ei zu essen
also ganz ganz gewöhnlich erst mal 3000
jahre später
eine formale
das habe ich hier schon ein motorrad
comma zur nächsten sache nummer zwei
saubere glühwürmchen wie ihr sie
wahrscheinlich noch nie gegessen habt
auch ihr leiter also machen sie ist auf
die suche nach wilden sachen
glühbirnchen und ich spreche so langsam
wenn wir sie nicht verschrecken
seht ihr dass leute ich habe im schwarm
gefunden ist muss sie eigentlich nur
noch hingehen wo es geht wie folgt müsst
euch einfach alle pärchen setzt zum
sprung an die opfer nicht lust hätte
können hier noch den rechtlichen schwarm
essen
hier haben wir haben wir hier wir wissen
ja viele von euch nicht aber so sehen
säure gewillt münchen in ihrer
natürlichen umgebung auch als nächstes s
papier sollte es papier was könnte heute
esspapier anders machen als normal
eigentlich ist relativ nahe liegend ich
meine was macht man mit stinknormalen
papier
man schreibt darauf was schreiben wir
drauf wir schreiben und mich bis zum
schluss hart jetzt abonniert mich jetzt
als jetzt keine aufforderung oder so von
übrigens ich bin mir bewusst dass das
nicht gesund ist also schleppt sich in
die kommentare
ziel ist es zu tun ist ich weiß auch was
zu tun ist
was machen wäre wohl aber lieber gesehen
das kann nicht gesund sein nummer vier
eine der lieblings süßigkeiten aus
meiner gesamten kindheit wie mega lange
hubba bubba schlange msi kran am harz
also wirklich ich habe früher eine zeit
da habe ich jeden tag 20 kilogramm
kaugummi gekaut und am liebsten dieses
hier und ihr könnt vielleicht schon
erahnen wie isst man es nicht viel spaß
die heilige rolle
euro der traum meiner kindheit leute das
nie mehr normal beim unterstufe leute
ich hab jetzt eine halbe schlange
rabobank probieren ein riesiges machen
kurve kriegen aber man kennt ihn aber
definitiv riesige blasen machen damit
zur nächsten sache nummer fünf ganz ganz
klassisch eine tafel schokolade so
tragischer tod
ist das spiel heute verdammt viel
schokolade schreibt mir auch gerne mal
ob er die süßigkeiten schon mal so
gegessen hat wie es in diesem video
mache also einfach mal war mit kaffee
schokolade reinbeißen anstatt sich
einfach irgendwelche stücke abzubrechen
oder so
die säure geschwister familie oder wer
auch immer war sechster süße mäuse die
fragt euch bestimmt wie kommen diese
süßen weise in die verpackung und um
dieses gefühl zu vermitteln
diese armen tiere gefangen werden möchte
euch mal zeigen wie es aussieht wenn man
diese diese kleinen viecher frisch fängt
womit fängt man mäuse klassischerweise
richtig mit einer mäuse falle als
allererstes platzierte die mäuse fallen
an einer sinnvollen stelle wo ihr hofft
oder denkt das süße mäuse vorbeikommt so
da heißt es nur noch abwarten bis
zufällig eine maus vorbeikommt und
schnapp habt ihr eure süße maus gefangen
können sie einfach essen
aber wir können einfach warten dass eine
maus geflogen kommen auf eure mäuse weil
es passiert teilweise auch und zack da
ist sie gefangen auch diese maus könnte
dann einfach wieder genießen
aber ich muss damit rechnen dass euch
die mäuse brüder angreifen bei ihr
arschlöcher sei keine frage aber
wirklich muss euch waren die rache der
mäuse kann schrecklich sein
und zu guter letzt brause wir sie noch
nie gegessen habt eine sache die ich als
echter gangster auch schon in frühen
kindertagen zu tun gepflegt habe pause
für die nase gangsters teil dafür
braucht ihr browser ein geldschein und
ihr müsst bereit sein euro schleimhäute
in der nase zu opfern
diese tue ich jetzt leute wandern wir
uns
ein gangster das was für heutigen video
ich musste mich und meine nase kümmern
macht es gut und ciao